oh we we watched League of Legends that
I guess I guess we didn't uh say that
but we went to watch uh the World
Championship uh for League of Legends
which we were planning this trip first
one the first one one yeah the first
that one that one that's literally what
it looks like that's smart it literally
comes like that I don't know I don't
know why mum don't do that but yeah we
went to Korea to watch The League of
Legends World final uh which we had been
planning for a while and we actually
tried to go as a little uh we we tried
to get Norm tickets at first mhm she
couldn't get them and that's the reason
by the way I wasn't in Korea yeah yeah
that's that's the reason Joey didn't go
it was me it was me Conor uh didus and
Emily so we were all like League of
Legends fans and we all stayed up at the
same time to get tickets for the World
Finals months ago and then within like
0.1 seconds they were gone they were
gone like you you we had like we had
like time this to the like almost like
the millisec everyone's like okay press
refresh fresh now and then it was like
you're in a queue of uh 7,000 people
yeah they were they were all gone they
were all gone uh within like I don't
know how you can't keep up with those
Korean we had to we had to we had to use
clout to get tickets like this is the
first knew a guy knew a guy yeah this is
the first time that I've ever used kind
of like my connections and my internet
which I hate doing I I [__] hate
doing this can you get me Le of Legend
tickets do you know who I am I'm G I I
[__] hate doing this but this is the
first time where if I did not if I was
like not in the position that I am in
now I do not know how I would get tiet
cuz I tried yeah we tried every Avenue
we could because uh we you know we we
didn't want to resort to this but
because we had no other choice I don't
want to Resort I don't like I you know I
I didn't like doing it to be honest you
just summon my final form yeah it
depends on like how close I am with
someone and like you know cuz if they're
like you're good friends with them you
be like hey man can I can I get sure if
you don't really know them it's like I
don't want to have to like owe someone
something I don't want to have to use my
clout to get it yeah it also feels bad I
get it yeah but you you know there's
nothing wrong with being like hey I'd
like to go would you guys you guys would
you how do you feel about that late how
you feel about that how does that make
you feel are you receptive to
that hey I I I I put in my hours I went
on the official League of Legends Tik
Tok stream what there oh yeah what yeah
I I I I met Raz through doing a jump my
jump King event where he was a
commentator on it and uh I I I was a
huge fan of like League of Legends so I
knew him oh you have to explain I assume
this guy's like a League of Legends
comment he's a League of Legends
commentator uh and I always thought he
he was so [__] cool uh and then when
he was commentating on this event with
me I was super stoked he was super super
nice and uh we ended up talking and then
uh I asked him for tickets to the New
York thing yeah and he managed to get me
them and I was like dude thanks man
appreciate it and then I I didn't ask
him this time we asked someone else uh
we got tickets and then he messaged me
while I was there he like do you want to
come on the on the stream I was like
what stream and he was like yeah just
come on over so I come on over and I'm
talking and sitting there I'm having to
talk with this other Pro and I'm like
I'm not a pro by the way I'm just here
to say things but it was fun it was nice
and I appreciate him and you know
invited me on pled in my hours see yeah
and and yeah and I mean like the
highlight of the event for me
unfortunately was probably just the
opening act yeah the opening act was the
best part there was like fireworks and
[__] I kind of sad that it was just 15
minutes I kind of wish it was like 30
yeah it kind of sounds like the Olympics
it it is cuz like the opening ceremonies
of it's kind of like the uh it's kind of
like the risk you take with buying
sporting events right which is
unfortunately like the two times I've
been to a League of Legends World final
both career uh it's just been a complete
stomp right right so it just ends super
quickly yeah it just ends super quickly
one of those times my the team I was
supporting was the team that got stomped
which was just like like it it was like
double whammy of just like oh it was a
stomp my team just sucks and there was
nothing to cheer for in this entire like
three-hour event that I was there for
but hey the opening act was really fun
and yeah cuz the game was two one-sided
to the point where it just wasn't fun
right uh there was
literally there was no tension the
everyone was rooting for the team that
was winning as well so everyone was
rooting but even in the last game
everyone was kind of like stopped
rooting as much they were like yeah it's
kind of you already killed him I think
it it was it was really fun though I
definitely want to go again what did you
think of the stadium experience like the
kind of like atmosphere cool it was
really cool kind of kind of hard to
watch though actually cuz you're like
turning your head to like look at the
big screen but and also cuz we were in
Korea I realized I was like damn I kind
of miss hearing all the commentating in
English and having their Insight oh cuz
all the com was in Korean it's all in
Korean in the stadium so I'm just kind
of having to watch it and make up my own
thoughts which is fine but I mean I like
sheep when they have no one to
follow well that well that's just like
it was really cool though yeah yeah
that's just every sporting event right
because you you go to a football match
and you're like oh [__] I can't where
are the commentators on the football
match well football football I felt like
it is I don't know it's different
football energy is way different to that
energy I felt like I felt you think so
yeah I think okay well I think there's
just a different energy in terms of the
place that you go to also the audience
is very different yeah the audience for
League fans are not like fo and football
fans the football fans will just start
chatting he's a [__] he's a [__]
then you're like I'll join
in there are so many like weird [__]
football CHS like he aedo
a and it's just like
normalized like damn you didn't have to
go that
hard the whole like you know I remember
distinctly that like if they ever get
close to the goal everyone stands up and
sits down it has this really thunderous
noise to it great [__] love football
games man it's just a different yeah I
feel like they're like people who watch
football are almost like professional
Watchers of of sports what what are you
what are you talking about like I think
people who like professional reaction
channels like people who people who go
to watch League of Legends are not
really Stadium goers generally right
they're not people who go to stadiums
they don't the yeah other than for like
one-off events whereas people who go to
watch football they have season tickets
they go every week you know they are
they are very very in the of like
Stadium kind of vibe and it makes a
different experience it's funny because
I remember when uh I remember there was
like some controversy uh controversy on
when League of Legends the world
championship was set in America and what
happened is one of the Korean teams was
facing an American team and when the
Korean team went like was introduced the
American audience booed
them and and they American respon and
they got so much flag for that but like
I'm actually going to defend the
Americans because because I'm like okay
yeah okay respect good play respect all
teams but it's a [__] sporting event
all right you should be allowed to boo
you should be allowed to boo if you like
I can't imagine like this is like the
test thing you could do in an English
football match like yeah booing booing
is like the least offensive thing that
happens yeah in the English football
match or just football matches in Europe
in general we're going to [__]
War the worst [__] ever I think it makes
really compelling stories as well like
having having someone be booed and then
maybe they come out on top and you know
maybe they win over the story yeah
there's I think that you should be
allowed to boo and cheer but the one
thing I I that I hate the most about uh
being in kind of uh more so that I've
realized Asian kind of stadiums I
haven't been in Japan much but when I've
watched them they they just make no
noise for the team they don't care about
which I feel like almost more offensive
because like oh my God you know in this
Stadium right T1 the Korean team the
most popular team in the world come out
it was Korea verus it it was Korea
versus
China this guy is H he's screaming at
his lung as a commentator he's
introducing the Chinese team like and we
have China and then quiet no one makes
[__] noise and I feel like that is so
insulting to not even give them any
vocal it was it was worse it was like
the I don't know how well this
translated on the broadcast but I
remember when they introduced the
Chinese theme there was a second silence
and then uh yeah yeah yeah lit literally
dead for a second you know what if I was
on stage I think I would prefer the
booze to I I I would prefer being booed
rather than having the pity clap of just
like yay yeah a couple of people
clapping sounds like horses [__] people
don't even care enough to give you an
emotion they don't even care enough
about you to to give a [__] it's it's
pretty close in Japan as well when I
went to go see a baseball match like
because the stadium is like perfectly
split up so one side of the stadium is
like one of the teams and the other side
yeah the away team and then one of them
is the home team and at the time we were
on the home team side um like not that I
really K I just wanted to go see the
game yeah but it was so funny cuz like
exactly the same home team comes on
everyone's standing up [__] shouting
spinning their towels around just being
like yeah let's [__] go moment the
away team comes on everyone just sits
down and just kind of looks so insulting
dude I mean come on every now and then
someone be like
yeah yeah I mean like there it's it's a
sporting event let's have some [__]
rivalries in there and let's like just
acknowledge that there's rivalries there
at least acknowledge the as long as long
as it stop you know doesn't go further
than booze you know I think it's all all
in good fun yeah exactly you know it's
you know as long as it's just like
little you know tongue and cheek playful
it's a sporting event we know it's a
sporting event I love that's why I love
fighting games Community they talk mad
trash they boo they cheer it's so fun to
watch get that boy some milk to me to me
the that's why the fighting Community
seems so fun because they seem like the
right level of toxicity yeah they're
they're all super into it and they're
all passionate in a way that I think
really translates to the viewer
experience you really care about these
stories because everyone around you is
so into it and that that really feeds
off like you feed off of that and that's
really important to have that in sport
yeah totally I think it's why football
has been so uh so like dominant in in
like Europe and other places you know
like South American stuff cuz it's just
it's such a passionate thing yeah uh
booing and cheering it's all part of the
yeah cuz you know we did have this world
championship in Korea so there was like
a home team there that people were going
toer for and that that was just like
that's why I'm excited for because next
year it's in Europe